faire des instruments qui coûte le moins
cher bon un instrument de base ne coûte
pas trop cher donc un enfant peut se
faire offrir lors des fêtes de noël
un harmonica donc c'est comme ça que
j'ai commencé avec un harmonica de bas
de gamme
et puis après quand j'ai puis de mes
poches acheter des harmonicas donc
j'achète des harmonicas un peu plus
sophistiquée d'harmonica diatonique
harmonica aromatiques mais harmonica
aussi avec plusieurs tonalités
exactement la monica pour matticks et
l'harmonica comme le piano qui permet de
tous les morceaux avec les altérations
donc comme celui que j'ai là lamonica
celui là c'est une harmonie cadeaux
comme le piano donc les notes blanches
ceux-là sans appuyer qu'on appuie sur la
tirette on allait les touches noires
c'est à dire les altérations diez et
bémol et les automnales it et c'est
groupé en mettre 2
une facilité plus de facilités pour
pouvoir accompagner certains musiciens
puisque jouer avec un seul harmonica
dans toutes les tonalités c'est pas
chose comme mode qu'est ce que ça
représente pour vous la faites de
l'harmonica
ce jury l'a fait de l'harmonica pour les
harmonicistes pour ce vraiment qu'ils
aiment l'harmonica c'est une occasion
une bonne occasion de jouer avec des
musiciens confirmés tels l'orgasme ou
dahico avec lequel de manuel ceinture
avec lequel va se produire jeudi
jeudi soir donc c'est pour nous une
occasion en fois trop rare de s'exprimer
convenablement